let's go now to the nearby state of
Nevada where the economy is a top
concern for voters headed to the polls
today and that could be complicated news
for Democrats Manuel bojorquez is in Las
Vegas for us Manny good morning
Good morning Tony a few things make
Nevada unique one as the iconic Vegas
strip illustrates is how largely tied to
tourism the state's economy is and that
took a big hit during the pandemic
shutdowns but also the current rate of
inflation here and gas prices are both
higher than the national average
Republicans are trying to capitalize on
that with the trump-backed Senate
candidate Adam laxalt tying those
pocketbook concerns to President Biden
and the incumbent Democrat Catherine
Cortez masto laxalt is especially
focused on winning a winning Latino
voters who are expected to make up 20
percent of the vote this cycle the
state's most powerful Union however the
culinary workers they've thrown their
support behind Cortez masto and the
members of that Union have knocked on
one million doors in Las Vegas and Reno
to try to get out the vote Cortez masto
was joined by Secretary of
Transportation Pete butterjudge last
night a final push to retain what some
have called the most vulnerable
Democratic seat in the Senate more than
600 000 early votes have been cast
according to State officials with
Republicans casting slightly more votes
than Democrats but 17 percent of those
votes come from people with no party
affiliation and that could make the
difference here Tony
yeah it's an important note there Manny
we should remember that most of this
country is not is not Democrats or
Republicans but in fact folks there in
the middle thank you and as I send it
back to you guys in New York I want to
underscore something that Chris said
this is election day we'll be going into
election night but we may not have calls
for every state by the time most people
go to bed today
that's good information to know Tony
will check back in with you a little bit
later